um let's use ali server he's probably
the most
forward-thinking um athlete in new
zealand right now so he could sell at
nft every single year and say like a
gold standard one would be worth
say say he's a hundred nfts and the gold
ones worth twenty thousand dollars so
instead of a business going to sponsor
the hurricanes um because they love
ariza via potentially they could sponsor
adi as a gold nft for twenty thousand
dollars but as a part of that token um
adi's going to give you two um you can
do two campaigns with him throughout the
year you get invited to his networking
space and dinners and the other guys
that have foreign the other
four holders of those gold nfts you get
a networking opportunities and you get
to like you know i mean you start to
think like that yeah
you tear it down to like a silver
version and silver version might get you
um a signed jersey from a blaze low cup
game and you get to rock up to a game
and that's fifteen thousand dollars
um then you go down there then you just
have all these different levels of
tokens and you can level it out like
that and and in that way a player can
maximize the potential of his own brand
without taking too much away from um
unless you like ad sponsors and and all
that sort of stuff like that so
i think that's going to be the way
forward and then that's when you'll see
guys and this is why i'm talking about
content right now yeah like you create
your content oh you start liking every
comment that's hey bro thank you thank
you thank you um thanks for coming to
the game appreciate you guys all that
sort of stuff hey guys i'm just in the
locker room after the game let's go have
a quick chat you build that community
you build that trust and when you drop
that product and as an nft
um you're gonna have a you can make
a bit of money and then um you can also
create like um make a change as well and
the fun thing about nfts bro once you
put them into a smart contract you can
have royalties off the back of that as
well so you might have a fan that's
bought a 100 nft and then say artie's
form starts going up
yeah and
you know i mean and that nft is worth
potentially 200 now if he sells that to
that person id can get a clip back on
the royalties as well
so